[Music]
israel's killing of al jazeera's shireen
abu akley and the occupied west bank
prompted ireland to call this meeting on
the protection of journalists at the
time of her killing
shireen was on duty in a blue press vest
a symbol which denotes civilian status
a symbol that demonstrates to parties to
conflict
that journalists are not a target
the targeting of journalists in conflict
zones is considered a war crime the
committee to protect journalists said no
less than 18 have been killed in the
palestinian territories in the last 20
years in ukraine nine journalists have
died in the war with russia
but as the experts made clear nine out
of ten such crimes are never prosecuted
the failure of states to investigate
prosecute and punish crimes against
journalists is not only a denial of
justice it is actually an encouragement
to perpetuate the cycle of violence
al jazeera's abdu rahim fukara promised
to pursue all legal options for
accountability
al-jazeera's position is crystal clear
shirin abu akla's life matters
and so does a transparent and
independent investigation of her killing
and of the serious violation of her
funeral
by the israeli security forces
there are other crystal clear issues for
al jazeera network
one
sharing abu agla was killed by an
israeli bullet and in cold blood while
she was doing her job
two
the network has the evidence and the
witnesses to support that position
other media networks have made the same
conclusion
the u.n security council has condemned
the killing of shireen abu aklay and
called for a transparent impartial
investigation but they haven't supported
the palestinian authority's call for an
investigation by the international
criminal court essentially leaving
accountability in israel's hands kristen
salumi al-jazeera the united nations